[Música]
los anales del rey del antiguo egipto
tutmosis tercero describieron un
maravilloso pájaro extranjero que daba a
luz diariamente los solo asturianos los
consideraban espíritus cuyos gritos
hablaban sobre la lucha cósmica entre la
oscuridad y la luz los romanos los
llevaron en sus campañas militares para
predecir el éxito de futuras batallas y
hoy este pájaro aún ocupa una importante
aunque mucho menos honorable posición en
nuestros platos
el pollo moderno desciende
principalmente del gallo banquina y
parcialmente de otras tres especies
estrechamente relacionadas todas nativas
de india y el sudeste de asia
el bambú de la región produce enormes
cantidades de frutas sólo una vez cada
pocas décadas la habilidad de la gallina
banquina para poner huevos a diario pudo
haber evolucionado para sacar partido a
estos raros festines incrementando su
población cuando la fruta era abundante
era algo que los humanos podían explotar
sobre una base consistente y la débil
capacidad de volar de las aves y su
limitada necesidad de espacio las hizo
fáciles de capturar y almacenar los
primeros pollos domesticados datan al
menos de hace siete mil años cuando no
fueron criados como comida sino para
algo considerado menos sabroso hoy en
día la agresividad de los machos
reproductores armados con escuelas
naturales en sus patas hizo de las
peleas de gallos un entretenimiento
popular para el segundo milenio antes de
cristo los pollos se habían extendido
desde el valle del indo a china y el
medio oriente para pertenecer a
colecciones reales y ser usados en
rituales religiosos pero fue en egipto
donde comenzó el siguiente capítulo de
la historia de estos pájaros
cuando una gallina encuba huevos de
forma natural dejará de ponerlos y se
sentará en una nidada de entre 6 o más
huevos por 21 días
para la mitad del primer milenio antes
de cristo los egipcios habían aprendido
a incubar artificialmente los huevos
colocándolos en canastas sobre cenizas
calientes
esto permitió a las gallinas continuar
poniendo huevos diariamente y lo que
había sido una delicia real o una
ofrenda religiosa se convirtió en una
comida común casi al mismo tiempo que
los egipcios incubaban huevos los
mercaderes fenicios introdujeron los
pollos en europa donde rápidamente se
convirtieron en parte esencial del
ganado europeo sin embargo durante mucho
tiempo el estatus venerado del pollo
continúa existiendo junto con su estatus
culinario los antiguos griegos usaban
gallos de pelea como ejemplos
inspiradores para los soldados jóvenes
los romanos consultaban a los pollos
como oráculos todavía en el siglo
séptimo el pollo fue considerado un
símbolo para el cristianismo durante los
siguientes siglos los pollos acompañaron
a los humanos por el comercio conquistas
y colonización
después de las guerras del opio las
razas chinas fueron llevadas a
inglaterra y las cruzaron con pollos
locales esto dio lugar a un fenómeno
llamado fiebre de la gallina o de france
y en que agricultores de europa se
esfuerzan en criar nuevas variedades con
combinaciones de rasgos particulares
esta tendencia llamó también la atención
de un tal charles darwin que se preguntó
si un proceso de reproducción selectiva
ocurrió en la naturaleza darwin
observaría a cientos de pollos mientras
finalizaba su histórico trabajo
introduciendo la teoría de la evolución
pero la mayor contribución del pollo a
la ciencia aún estaba por llegar a
principios del siglo 20 un trío de
científicos británicos llevó a cabo
extensos cruces de pollos realizados
sobre el trabajo de gregor mendel sobre
la herencia genética
con su alta diversidad genética muchos
rasgos distintos y sólo siete meses
entre generaciones los pollos eran los
sujetos perfectos este trabajo resultó
en el famoso cuadro de planet usado para
mostrar los genotipos resultantes de la
reproducción de un par determinado dado
desde entonces iniciativas de cría se
hicieron más grandes y carnosos y les
permitió poner más huevos que nunca
mientras tanto la producción de pollos
ha cambiado a un modelo industrial como
una fábrica con aves criadas en espacios
no más grandes que una hoja de papel y
si bien ha habido un cambio a la
agricultura en libertad por los derechos
animales y preocupaciones ambientales la
mayoría de los más de 22 mil millones de
pollos hoy en día son de cría industrial
desde gladiadores a regalos para los
dioses a compañeros de viaje y sujetos
de investigación los pollos han tenido
muchos papeles a lo largo de los siglos
y a pesar de que no hayan llegado antes
del proverbial huevo la fascinante
historia de los pollos nos dice mucho de
la nuestra
eres estudiante de historia entonces
suscríbete a nuestro canal para aprender
de todo desde la historia del chocolate
hasta la peor monja de la historia y la
historia de los colores más mortíferos
del mundo sigue conectado si tienes
curiosidad